moving to l.a did was there any sort of
period of time where you felt
you know like overwhelmed with this [ __ ]
boy [ __ ] i feel kind of overwhelmed
right now it's like a constant
state of being overwhelmed and adapting
it's how far you want to go what level
are you trying to adapt to
for yourself your own personal goals and
your career
and your mental happiness but it's never
going to stop
until you become like a legacy act but
even then
these these people these artists have
just built the infrastructure around
them to deal with that constant like
mental attack because it's that forever
and the internet will
solidify that [ __ ] because when you're
not dealing with the sauce to get lost
in outside you're dealing with it on
your phone
yeah you're dealing with in your email
on zoom calls
you know what i'm saying like this [ __ ]
is forever that's the job
so it's about how much you want to take
and like i said it's some [ __ ] that i
got to deal with currently
and until i figure it's like absolutely
too much
then maybe i'll do that but i have been
thinking about um
just getting another spot somewhere to
like
clear myself for this la [ __ ] especially
because
when you live in l.a you still got to
deal with
being a transplant because i'm not from
here i know a lot of people from here
and i respect their rules and
regulations of their game however
but like you you still got to be in this
city and and navigate
such the thickness of the sauce
and it's crazy because the world's shut
down so you're trying to navigate in the
same way that you're
just when the world was open and
especially here yeah
really shut the [ __ ] down it shut the
[ __ ] down so it's like damn
why am i even here i'm dealing with all
of this [ __ ] just to like be here i
don't even need to be here right now
yeah the homie uh i got a homie uh who's
a rapper mike stud and he
he um he just said [ __ ] it and he went
to arizona
for like two months and now he's in
montana he's just like
he's like i gotta get the [ __ ] out of la
man like if there's a time to just take
a break and unplug it's like
while everything's shut down